it's not that easy but they make it
really easy I'm going to buy a surfboard
I'll buy it from you guys and you buy it
and then you never get up again exactly
they even had a dog that surfed when I
was there right well it's easier for
dogs four legs exactly yeah they just
mooved backwards so which is why I
surfed on all fours you surfed on all
fours that doesn't
count it doesn't count when you do it
do it doesn't when on a if you do it
doggy style on a surfboard it doesn't
count
oh I'm so R now let me just get this
open and then you know third time a
charm on the show right is this your
third time on the
show like this is the make out
date first
be you wouldn't be that happy if it was
true here you can you take mine and then
I'll get yours
out it's an Affliction here just what
you BW in there I know how to do it
I'm sure you
do apparently
not just blow a little softer more
consistently you'll be
fine oh the horse thinks it's funny yeah
the
hes I also like your horse you like my
horse I grew up with horses in a stable
um we didn't actually have a St
he was in the padic Oh I thought you
were like raised by
horses no I grew up riding horses oh
that see that's a great thing do are you
going to teach your you going to teach
your your kid to ride horses yeah but
when he's finished with the
piano once he's done with the piano I
think I might teach him to ride a horse
yeah I think I like it yeah me too and I
had a lot of fun on on the back of a
horse what are we talking
about
hey hey
hey no I'm blushing yeah listen you
you're blush you walk up and down with
your underwear but this is what makes
you blush I love your blue eyes I love
everything about
you I I'm no longer and and he's gay you
know yeah not anymore yeah no cuz it's
got that like
rubbery
texture is the word I was going for so
that you base your diet on texture I do
I do totally based my diet so do you
like soft foods or hard food I don't
like clementines the way they kind of
taste in your mouth when they you mean
the small oranges clementines adorable
mandarins mandarins tangerines
clementines they're all kind of the same
thing I look forward to your
letters I think they're all they're all
small tasty fruit balls yeah but they
break apart in your mouth in a really
kind of unpleasant way you don't like
that no well what do you like to feel in
your
mouth it's a perfectly legitimate
question to someone who bases their diet
on
texture what kind of texture do you
enjoy crunchy you know sort of
reliable
reliable what kind of what kind of
doctor is your sister Internal Medicine
internal medicine so all her work is
done indoors
what does that mean internal medicine
that means like it's all organs no she
doesn't do hair no I
not that was a really good
one no it wasn't KN it off you're just
showing your teeth for
money oh you are you saying lawyers are
corrupt come on now I would never say
that man I hate lawyers Tak can civil
I do man you're not a lawyer are you
before you were an actress you didn't
sneak in a bit of law in did you what's
in that what's in this
[Applause]
confidence have you always been this
quick some things
I some things I am a little slow
with such
as physical activities
can I tell you something about this why
do I have a hunchback yeah can I tell
you something about this why do you look
like a
[Music]
dude why why wouldn't they make it more
flattering perhaps give me better
posture yeah you want to be if you're in
a video game you want a hunchback that's
what I'm saying yeah you want the tomb
Raiders right
there that's the point of being in a
video game you want the Lara crof SE I
tried Craig it didn't work that's all
right you don't need him thanks
Craig that's how you talk to women
guys you don't need them
honey hey tell us your opinion about
stuff that too that
works who's the who's the gentleman with
whose man boob you fell uh Chris Evans
who plays Captain America I don't think
he I don't think he has man Bobs though
he's got firm chly areas well they were
absolutely enormous though I mean
um you know coming from you that's a
hell of a thing to say oh my god
oh
I I am a really I'm good you know to eat
and
I thank you that was good that was good
thank you I'm here to help all
right I like that I like you
the uh male heterosexuals are more
attracted to slightly larger uh females
I okay
yeah you got any cookies back there yeah
yeah you want some tea
I it's true though I have to tell you
that every time I eat myself up a little
bit your husband get a little bit frisky
yeah that's right he gets a little hands
on I love it's great you see what
happens is I I think dress designers are
like no you've got to be thin so that
the clothes look like that but you see
men who are not involved in dress design
they're not caring about the clothes
staying
on exactly they like Baby It's You know
and if it's too uncomfortable take it
off yeah that's fine but the shoes stay
on is that is that good yeah that's very
good come on yes yes ex fact there's a
giant camera and there's you know our
whole crew is sitting around us and
stuff like that and they're like okay so
just look directly into the camera which
is a security camera and just just SE it
up just sex it up cuz I'm trying to get
this I do that here every night look at
the camera and sex it
up that's all right that's what I know I
kind of look a little bit kind of crazy
I understand but but just what you do is
you go like this you can mus up your
hair and then play with your
lips oh go on do you know how long I've
just been through make right well you
can you can just go like this sorry Alex
and then try to look like you can't you
can't remember what you were thinking
like I forgot what
I is that kind I'm too sexy to remember
things I
need you free my
mind I Need Your
Love yeah you free my
mind
we're out of time that's it yeah yeah
why is it going by so fast if I could
tell you the M time woman have said that
to
me hm mouth organ or awkward pause uh
awkward pause really yeah you surprised
me interesting you thought I thought
mouth organ all right give me mouth
organ all right then I'll give you mouth
organ but first here's the harmonica
okay
you know my dad watch it was a joke it
was a joke I didn't mean it it was a
joke I couldn't it was stupid I'm sorry
I didn't mean to be too it's a stupid
joke I'm sorry Mr
Kunis here we go all
right take your time take your time
don't just rush in there blowing and
sucking and
chewing take your
time I I'm telling you hav play
harmonica oh my
God especially I noticed if you waiting
tables the Swanky or the restaurant the
more Sashi meat eat there have you
noticed that yeah absolutely it's like
wow yeah and they don't tip either
especially when you yell at them well I
have boob well yeah but you know I have
boobs so you do I got I got I got some
nice tips I don't know I don't know
about you what do I
say right hold on they know yeah no I'm
just slowing things down for the person
that types out for the uh for the
audience who heart of hearing t i p
s
nice you know English is not my first
language
either not right now anyway uh if you
were in an orgy what would be your
position guitar or no
guitar
[Applause]
scum scum or pluck scrum or
pluck I I actually like to strum and
pluck is that okay that's good yeah I'm
European so I can do both at the same
time and I love playing guitar but
there's a lot of other people who play
guitar better than me so I would
actually probably I'd have a little
strum and a little plaque but then I'd
pass it on to maybe a really
good-looking male who was really amazing
at playing guitar and then continue the
a
wait wait wait wait no no no no none of
that was a about guitar was it yeah